de la méthode de désignation d'un
candidat à la présidentielle jean
leonetti présente ses pistes demain en
fin d'après midi lors d'un bureau
politique très attendu
il veut donc une primaire ouverte de la
droite et du centre mais la question est
aussi faut-il accélérer le calendrier
beaucoup le souhaitent
ici au sénat on va ouvrir le débat avec
nos invités dans un instant d'avoir les
éléments de contexte avec jérôme rabin
le répit des bons résultats aux
régionales et départementales aura été
de courte durée
les républicains se retrouvent demain
17h pour un bureau politique à hauts
risques face à christian jacob qui
préféreraient attendre la rentrée pour
choisir une méthode de départage et qui
ne veut pas de primaire de nombreux élus
vont plaider pour une accélération du
calendrier
auteur d'une motion signée par plus de
90 sénateur roger karoutchi plaide pour
appuyer sur l'accélérateur et il estime
avoir été entendu ce que je souhaitais
est-ce que les cheveux longs on a plus
ou moins obtenu c'est que le bureau
politique de demain soit saisie de la
méthode
qu'est-ce qu'on choisit si demain on
nous dit voilà on ouvre la possibilité
d'une primaire qu'ensuite les conditions
exactes technique et tout soit décidé
qu'au mois de septembre
mais au moins tout le monde saura que on
peut avancer et les candidats potentiels
peuvent se manifester et chacun fera sa
campagne après chacun fait ses choix
c'est donc bien vers une primaire que
l'on s'oriente jean leonetti qui est
chargé de préparer cette échéance a
dévoilé sa stratégie dans le jdd est
pour lui une évidence s'impose elle ne
peut être couverte
si nous décidions d'interroger nos seuls
militants-- l'air comment pourrions nous
demander à valérie pécresse xavier
bertrand ou nos amis centristes d'y
participer
xavier bertrand qui peut désormais
compter sur un nouveau soutien en
interne le vice-président du parti
guillaume pelletier voit en lui un
candidat naturel
le président de la région hôte français
candidats déjà déclarés a toujours dit
qu'il ne se soumettrait pas un scrutin
espérant un ralliement de son ancien
parti derrière lui mais il sait aussi
qu'il ne peut espérer se qualifier si un
deuxième candidat issu dlr est sur la
ligne de départ
autant de questions qui devront être
débattue demain et peut être tranchée
pour lancer la campagne présidentielle
d'une droite qui rêve de revanche
quatre ans après avoir été éliminé au
premier tour de la présidentielle avec
nous pour ce match des idées ce soit
roxane lundi bienvenue membre de la
direction nationale génération
conseillère municipale à beauvais
corentin le furent bienvenue avant
sûrement vous êtes conseiller municipal
lr d'eaubonne dans le val d'oise et
conseiller national du parti a l'air
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
ici corentin le furent beaucoup de
sénateurs 92 pour être précise demandent
une accélération du calendrier ils
veulent surfer si j'ose dire sur la
dynamique des régionales ils ont raison
alors sur la partie essentiellement du
calendrier oui je pense qu'ils ont
raison
la date du mois de novembre qui a été
annoncé en deadline finale pour avoir
faim pour que la droite puisse se doter
d'un candidat me sens effectivement
beaucoup trop tardive par rapport à la
dynamique
on ne peut pas attendre aussi
tardivement puisque non seulement
d'autres candidats par rapport à
d'autres parties on va dire concurrents
se seront positionnés et y compris au
sein d'une des mouvements de la droite
et du centre on sait très bien que
certains candidats fortement tentés d'y
aller n'attendront pas une telle date et
donc ça peut favoriser des initiatives
individuelles ou des départs de courses
anticipées alors que justement répartir
de manière anticipée bertron peut-être
peut-être d'autres candidats jeu ça
donnerai pas de nom peut-être peut-être
d'autres candidats qui saurait la
nunuche donnerai pas de noms mais à
vouloir partir de manière anticipée
puisque s'il ya une inertie de
l'appareil qui est trop lente c'est une
opportunité pour dire moi je suis au
delà des différents appareils des
différentes structures je pars voilà
tant que je pense que c'est
effectivement beaucoup trop tardif
il faut que la question soit réglée pour
le milieu de l'automne et on apprend ce
soir qu'une tribune est publiée sur le
site du figaro signé par valérie
pécresse laurent wauquiez bruno
retailleau hervé morin c'est un appel
pour une primaire ouverte de la droite
et du centre
son sondage sans passer par cette
méthode du sondage dont la fiabilité est
plus que jamais mis en doute comme
envoyer tout cela et roxanne lundi
écoutez moi je suis toujours favorable
aux primaires parce que ça permet de
pratiquer donc c'est plutôt une très
bonne chose il appartient la droite
maintenant de désigner son candidat mais
y'en a déjà candidat de droite se
déclarer à cette élection président
elle c'est président de la république
est donc aujourd'hui à l'air et la
réalité le montre le président en a
aujourd'hui de toute manière ces
affiches et s'est affirmée alors de
toutes ces élections régionales et
départementales comme un candidat de la
droite en allant jusqu'à renvoyer
parfois de manière honteuse la gauche au
même niveau que l'extrême droite
je tiens à le dire puisque ça a été fait
notamment en ile-de-france et dans un
certain nombre de régions un propos de
la france un sou mizoulina même bien sûr
je pense à aux propos d'olivier des
rangs qui a été jusqu'à comparer la
gauche et l'extrême droite ce qui est
honteux quand on connaît l'histoire de
l'extrême droite quand on connaît notre
histoire politique
c'est absolument dramatique mais ils se
sont positionnés sur un créneau très à
droite et donc aujourd'hui vous avez un
candidat à droite qui est président de
la république emmanuel macron qui assume
un bilan de droite et je crois que votre
premier candidat est déjà parti donc il
vous appartiendra maintenant de désigner
un candidat de l'appareil mais mais je
crois qu'en tout cas dans le jeu il
faudra bien compter sur sa présence dans
l'échec est donc déjà deux candidats de
la droite a le plus ancien de nos 1022
corentin pas tout à fait on va dire que
bon jeu il ya évidemment la boutade
ensuite sur la partie plus sérieuse pour
rejoindre sur évidemment qu'une seule
partie du propos madame c'est que le
président de la république
autant il ya l'enjeu de la
présidentielle qui se fait uniquement
sur son nom puisque lrm n'existe pas en
tant que parti on l'a bien vu aux
dernières élections il incarne à lui
seul ce qui est en mesure d'incarner par
contre pour l'enjeu des législatives le
président de la république sait
parfaitement que s'il devait miser sur
sa majorité actuelle il serait
minoritaire à l'assemblée nationale
puisque beaucoup de députés rm qui sont
totalement désincarné n'incarne pas
grand chose risque d'être balayés aux
prochaines législatives est donc tactile
sont pas là pour se défendre son nom
mais c'est plus un constat
donc vous le président de la république
sait très bien qu'il va devoir
rééquilibrer le centre de gravité de sa
majorité sur la droite
à l'échéance des prochaines législatives
au cou besoin de rééquilibrer ces camps
mais les suicides alors qu'ils ont été
saisis quand même très clair avec en
plus un agenda politique surtout les
débats qui sont portées aujourd'hui dans
le débat politique de manière plus
goldman va s'exprimer sur un plateau
télévisé face à madame le pen et qu'il
explique à madame le pen qu'elle est
trop molle je crois pas qu'aujourd'hui
nous ayons un gouvernement très très
clairement il a été prise de position
très claire dans presque tous les
territoires
les représentants de la république en
marche son parti avec la droite parfois
des premiers tours parfois sur le second
tour parfois non cucq appelé à voter
pour le candidat de la droite mais à
aucun moment il y ait eu la moindre
ambiguïté entre la gauche et les
écologistes d'une part et le
gouvernement droite ni de gauche est
complètement si le gouvernement copie la
droite les dernières élections semblent
montrer que les électeurs ont préféré
l'original de la copie
bah je ne dis pas le combat je ne dis
pas le contraire aujourd'hui que nous
avons un échec de la république en
marche qui est très clair avec son
revers terrible mais le premier revers
je crois d'abord sur c'était sur ces
élection est l'abstention il faut
l'avoir en tête ce qui montre bien
l'impopularité du président de la
république parce que le pari des manuels
macron était dire nous allons faire
autre chose nous allons remobiliser nous
allons rénover nos institutions
le bilan c'est que nous sommes à un
niveau d'abstention qui n'a jamais été
atteint et qu'en effet quand il y à
choisir entre la droite et la droite de
l air à la droite du président de la
république
souvent c'est la droite de l r je ne
sais pas ce qu'il en sera pour la
présidentielle parce que c'est un parti
qui s'est construit autour de l'ultra
personnifie personnification
personnalisation du pouvoir du président
la paix comme si je cogite me permettre
de revenir sur ce que vous annonciez la
tribune qui est très récente moi je
pense enfin je salue effectivement cette
tribune
d'autant plus qu'elle est signée par de
probables futurs concurrents
parce que voilà les fameux par exemple
par exemple décision il faut réfléchir
maintenant la réflexion mais mais oui on
choisit pas un candidat fn si l'on
choisit pas un camp avec des sondages
surtout quand on voit la fiabilité ces
fameux sondages
à partir du moment où on souhaite avoir
une droite qui est réunie puisque là la
condition sinequanone de la réussite
c'est d'avoir un ou une candidate mais
qui réunit l'ensemble de 700 suite à
droite il faut avoir un mode de
départage qui soit un mode de départage
objectif à la régulière si je puis dire
et donc on a que le système de la
primaire on a dit beaucoup de mal de la
primaire de 2016 mais le promettait pas
la primaire de 2016 c'est les péripéties
ve pourrait dire qu'ils sont arrivés à
partir du mois de janvier février sur le
candidat fillon mais la primaire a
montré que l'on pouvait avoir un
véritable exercice démocratique certes
vous avez des gens de gauche qui
viennent voter de manière marginale mais
ça n'influence pas évidemment le
résultat global et ça a permis de faire
émerger un candidat qui à l'époque
n'était absolument pas envisagé dans les
sondages qui nous vendaient absolument
un duel sarkozy joue tant les sondages
vais vous quand même vous en citer un
celui de l'ifop publiée par le jdd
46% des sondés estiment que xavier
bertrand ferait un bon candidat de la
droite seul qui se déclarerait voilà 42%
pour valérie pécresse 38% françois
baroin 35% laurent wauquiez 32% michel
barnier 18% bruno retailleau
bon c'est parce qu'il s'est déjà déclaré
qu'il est le fait qu'ils se soient déjà
déclaré qu'ils se déclarent assez
régulièrement d'ailleurs naturellement
donné
donné on va dire un réflexe auprès de
l'électeur en dix ans actuellement c'est
lui qui déclare mais on n'est pas dans
un exercice de jeu placé il faut il faut
avoir la légitimité et les élections
régionales ne l'ont pas permis puisque
monsieur bertrand monsieur wauquiez même
pécresse ont été confortablement réélu
dans la région respective donc il n'y a
pas eu de match n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
candidat naturel
quoi qu'on en dise je suis assez frappé
de nous entendre défendre à ce point le
système des primaires aussi vous aussi
de votre côté roxane lundi du point de
vue du public qui ne connaît pas grand
chose il voit surtout des gens qui se
dispute entre eux dans un parti alors
qu'à priori sont censés avoir à peu près
les mêmes idées beaucoup parlent même de
machine à perdre
c'est étonnant de le défendre à ce point
les gens n'ont pas confiance dans la
politique ni dans les politiques et tout
d'un coup on niveau se disputer entre
eux croient que c'est sain
de manière générale on a besoin de débat
démocratique d'abord je pense qu'on sort
toujours enrichie du débat démocratique
alors entre vous sans être filmé sans
parce que ça donne lieu à des émissions
de télévision je pense qu'il faut pas
avoir peur de la démocratie
faut pas penser que quand on a quand on
ouvre les choses quand on est du débat
alors forcément on risque de voir des
candidats qui ne devra pas gagné
l'emporter je pense qu'il faut faire
confiance à la majorité mais vous feriez
de l'abstention les français quand ils
voient à la télévision
mais marc demandant ce qui se passe il
va être un deuxième sujet c'est la
question par contre de la clarification
de comment est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
pour avoir des responsables politiques
qui se montrent à la hauteur du moment
je tiens à le dire quand même eu alors
oui sur la primaire de la droiture à un
peu de clarification à faire parce
qu'entre les positions de madame morano
qui de plus en plus quand même ne sera
pas complètement fait exploser les
digues qui séparait encore les dykes
sanitaires nécessaires qui séparait
encore la droite républicaine de
l'extrême droite avec des positions qui
pour beaucoup mais c'est pareil à gauche
au sein de l'église
les gauches d'ailleurs yannick jadot
eric piolle ali delgo jir toutes ces
gauches l'appareil énormément de
différences dans les discours le premier
sujet c'est d'arriver à se mettre
d'accord sur un projet et c'est ce que
permettent les primaires il nous avons
une primaire écologiste qui se tiendra
en septembre qui vise à départager les
candidats de l'écologie politique c'est
essentiel d'avoir ces moments parce que
chaque candidature ne doit pas se
construire de manière ultra
personnalisés mes doigts de partir d'un
collectif et ça c'est essentiel et c'est
d'ailleurs les rohff fondamental ce qui
fait qu emmanuel macron ne sera pas
réélu
si ça continue parce que ce nous avons
un président impopulaire parce qu'il
s'est fait élire seul et qui n'a pas
construit de collectif nous avons besoin
d'avoir ce collectif parce que demain
quand on voit les élus locaux dans les
territoires les grands élus qui font un
travail à l'assemblée nationale dans les
municipalités dans les différents
hémicycle ce sont eux qui au quotidien
aussi construisent et bâtissent des
majorités politiques
alors nous avons besoin de construire ce
collectif avec des militants pour
clarifier les choses d'abord sur le
terrain des valeurs et je pense que
c'est l'essentiel
toro toujours revenir au projet est
derrière se mettent d'accord sur celui
qui leur présentent la pression on s'en
fiche
en tout cas moi je suis faire et cela
donne de voir un seul homme c'est parce
qu'ils le ballon pendant justement parce
qu'on parle beaucoup des personnes des
images mais il faut effectivement
beaucoup parler du fond d'abord un débat
de primaire peut être respectueux parce
qu'on pourrait avoir du coup la même
question avec le débat de la
présidentielle avec les candidats qu'on
n'a pas toujours vu des débats qui nous
ont enrichi fortement intellectuellement
et surtout parce qu'il faut
effectivement clarifier la droite depuis
très longtemps est assez pluriel
il ya un discours qui donne le la
primaire est également l'occasion pour
chaque candidat qu'ils soient connus ou
moins connus d'apporter sa vision sur le
régalien sur l'économique sur les
questions européennes
et ça je pense que les électeurs ont
aussi envie de savoir par exemple la
droite depuis très longtemps et sur une
ligne par exemple économique qui est
quand même assez interventionniste ou
assez étatiste et on constate une
appétence une aspiration véronique un
peu plus libéral et je pense que ça doit
être aussi intéressant débattre du fond
pas que de la personne
allez on parle du r'n si vous le voulez
bien
il y aura pas changement de ligne du
côté du rassemblement national c'est
bien ce qu'a confirmé marine le pen hier
en congrès à perpignan nous ne
reviendrons pas en arrière dit-elle avec
tout le respect que nous avons pour
notre histoire nous ne reviendrons pas
au fn a martelé la présidente du parti
sauf que voilà ce refus de changer de
ligne ne plaît pas à tout le monde ce
matin sur public sénat c'est le maire et
rennes de moissac qui a tiré à boulet
rouge sur la stratégie du parti candidat
parachuté implantation locale négliger
verticalité voilà son bilan à lui
écouter ce que le projet durera sûrement
nationale ce qu'aujourd'hui on a on y
réagit par une verticalité en
fertilisant qui les montrent qu'on n'a
pas confiance à l'entreprise cette
verticalité utilisant se traduit par
quoi se traduit par une communication
totalement préparés à travers des kits à
nanterre qui sont ensuite plus ou moins
de poser à nos candidats sur des
municipales or quand on fait des kits
avec une vision nationale donc avec par
exemple la photo de marine le pen sur
sur les traquer profession de foi et
avec des discours totalement nationaux
on tombe à côté de la plaque on à côté
de la plaque vis-à-vis des réalités de
chaque territoire
alors on en parlait avec vous sur ce
plateau on va cueillir dans ce match
jean lain la capelle bienvenue vous êtes
eurodéputés et délégué national du rnd
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
critiques assez virulente
oui on n'a pas ces critiques qui sont
bien sûr du tout légitimes interne en g3
carignan david rachline si les oies à
hénin-beaumont julien sanchez au caire
tout c est avec plus de 60% des voix
résonne ici pâle et croyez moi on me
parle de likouala bien sûr tout document
niveau de support le sujet n'est pas là
tournons maintenant parce que monsieur
votre témoin
le maire de moissac évoqué une élection
municipale nous ne sommes plus dans une
action 10 balles
nous sommes aux élections nationales
avec les thématiques nationales qui
doivent considérer des produits passion
des français et des sujets sur lesquels
lorsque nationale a les solutions
concrètes sur lesquelles notre candidate
donc vous avez compris qu'elle ne serait
plus la candidate exclusivement de
l'assemblée nationale et qu'elle serait
la candidate de la france et sur la
kander les patriotes qui allait serrer
de rassembler tous les patriotes en
france pour essayer de réduire ses 50%
nécessaires à gagner l'élection
présidentielle
et bien notre candidate marine le pen je
crois la solution concrets pour l
occupation et aux problèmes des français
alors quand marine le pen dit qu'elle ne
veut pas revenir au temps du front
national qu'est ce que ça veut dire très
concrètement ça veut dire qu'on va vous
continuer la stratégie de la
normalisation de la dédiabolisation
comme on l'a beaucoup entendu mais quand
vous êtes qualifiés dans les opinions au
second tour qu'en 2017
vous avez été dans l'élection nationale
présidentielle vous avez été qualifié
pour le second tour que lors de nexon
europe est une élection nationale
nous avons gagné avec 24% des suffrages
élections européennes les côtés oui il
ne faut pas changer de ligne et je pense
que je pense que nos fondamentaux sur
les bons et qu'on les a trahis et un
jour on nous reproche c'est trop dur à
l'autre joueur all that outre tout je
crois très sincèrement la fidélité à nos
fondamentaux
je crois que c'est celle-ci qui va nous
récompenser et que nous sommes légitimes
parce que nous avons eu raison surtout
sur des sujets sur le sujet comme
l'islam radical sur le super de
l'insécurité sur les sujets comme
l'immigration dont personne ne voulait
parler donc tout le monde est
responsable complices et coupables 2010
les mails ou des nous nous avons les
solutions et aujourd'hui elles sont
opposables aux mrc acquis par les mots
les reprennent mais par les actes ne les
appliquent pas sur les sujets comme la
souveraineté industrielle la crise à
l'idéal entre que le contrôle des
frontières est important que l'aso lors
des
comique sur des masses des vaccins
aurait étape importante sur la fausse
écologie dont on nous parle sur les
sujets comme la grande réforme fiscale
qu'il faut mettre en place ce doux
ségéla nous avons un programme donc des
solutions et donc les nôtres
à peine dévoilés au fil de la campagne
il nous reste dix mois alors restez avec
nous aux gens dans la capelle si la
liaison fonctionne je vous invite à
écouter ce que vont peut-être vous
répondre nos invités en plateau ils ont
eu raison avant tout le monde et ils ont
eu des solutions concrètes avant tout le
monde roxane lundi mais alors je suis
abasourdi par ce que j'entends bien sûr
que marine le pen n'a pas changé de
positionnement politique c'est toujours
le même alors on l'a appelée front
national maintenant sous le terme de
rassemblement national
elle explique qu'elle ne veut pas
revenir au front national fait tout ça
ce sont des mots c'est du verbiage les
premiers thèmes qui nous sont donnés ce
soir c'est l'islam radical l'immigration
la sécurité
enfin le problème le premier problème
aujourd'hui d'un sécurité nationale
c'est le dérèglement climatique
voilà ça c'est une réalité quand on voit
qu'il ya des villes entières qui sont en
train de brûler qu on est en train
d'atteindre un des épisodes de
dérèglement climatique terrible qui
menacent nos territoires se sont salées
vrai sujet au lieu de ça ils sont
toujours dans leur même obsession
l'obsession identitaire
l'obsession bien sûr de l'islam
l'obsession manière plus générale de
l'insécurité fantasmer donc oui madame
le pen a toujours surfé sur les colères
ça continue elle ne change pas c'est sa
ligne politique c'est l'extrême droite
il faut arrêter de dédiaboliser
l'extrême droite l'extrême droite c'est
une histoire politique pour vous au fn
et rennes cela me laisse exactement la
même chose alors ils peuvent changer de
nom autant qu'ils veulent ils peuvent
changer les visages les rajeunir les
viennois ça a semblé décevoir un certain
nombre d'électeurs qui ne se sont
abstenus aux régionales dont il est
qu'il a peut-être changé quand même une
partie moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité aujourd'hui dans notre pays qui
est favorable aux thèses du
rassemblement national et du front
national
la réalité se soient obtenues par des
accords mais se sont abstenus parce que
le parquet fasse réellement interrogé
sur le fond c'est pas le problème de la
normalisation du parti au contraire
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin d'avoir
des alternative républicaine dans ce
pays
le vrai problème que nous avons c'est
que marine le pen n'arrive pas à
convaincre sur le fond parce que les
propositions qu'elle façon dans ce
décalage complet avec les vraies
attentes
aujourd'hui la jeunesse qui marche pour
le climat qui explique qu'elles arrêtent
parfois d'aller à l'école parce qu'elle
ne sait pas quel sera son avenir
et qu'il ya toute cette incertitude
quant à ce qui va se passer dans les
années qui viennent
comment est ce que vous voulez que
marine le pen lui apporte des solutions
des gens qui sont en colère et ils ne
sont pas sensibles au discours de madame
le pen parce que les deux grande
insécurité aujourd'hui c'est la crise
sociale et la crise climatique
donc elle est à côté de la plaque et oui
madame le pen est has been corps
interruption il ya la partie fonds frais
pied à la partie forme
sur le lorrain l'ancien front national
devenu rassemblement national a réussi
petit à petit a augmenté la masse
critique de l'électorat effectivement en
allant chercher des nouveaux visages au
niveau de la jeunesse
et puis effectivement en faisant ce
qu'on a appelé cette fameuse opération
de dédiabolisation en évitant les
dérapages les sorties que ça en tout cas
au niveau 1 au niveau national il ya
aussi l'époque
florian philippot qui a effectivement de
par son héritage chevènementiste essayer
d'équilibrer de dalles et de revenir
vers une ligne qui en apparence de
devait se présenter plus sociale
et ça a marché au niveau de l'évolution
de lectorat bon o'neill ya eu cette
forme
ensuite il ya eu la partie mutation sur
le fond on se souvient de la marine le
pen candidate du débat de 2010 est très
fortement fragilisé et visé face à
emmanuel macron pas les aussi vraiment
asie a eu un coup de grâce sur les
questions économiques et depuis ben on
sent qu'il ya la volonté de travailler
le fond des dossiers d'apparaître un peu
plus crédible sur le fond parce que
hausse au final c'est souvent la
critique qui est fait à l'interné mieux
politique c'est que c'est là paraît
absolument pas crédible sur les dossiers
de fond donc marine le pen quelque part
il pouvait pas se passer grand chose en
fait à ce congrès est là une dernière
carte à jouer qui est cette
présidentielle parce qu'il ya eu un
premier échec
il y avait un deuxième échec avec
qualification un peu au second tour si
je prends à chaque présidentielle et là
il ya ensuite cette présidentielle c'est
la dernière carte à jouer si marine le
pen n'est pas présente de la république
cette fois ci je pense qu nettement
l'avenir politique ce sera terminé je
dis pas has been dit il ya il ya
quelques mois à faire maintenant
là où il ya également vu un autre un
aspect sur la forme il ya une
contre-performance du rassemblement
national aux élections locales mais
parce que c'était des élections locales
et que majoritairement cette élection a
été une élection de prime aux sortants
de gauche ou de droite et le
rassemblement national a fait une trêve
une très forte contre performance mais
quand on regarde les sondages au niveau
national
marine le pen ne dégringolent pas dans
les sondages donc tout simplement il y a
j'imagine et légendes plus voter
j'imagine cette idée de dire si on
mobilise notre électorat et qu'on
continue sur cette ligne là et comme la
droite est en train de se chercher un
candidat parce que nous avons aussi
perdu beaucoup de nos électeurs à droite
qui sont partis au rassemblement
national on le sait très bien
eh bien il ya cette tentation de dire en
fait on n'a pas grand chose d'autre à
faire et qui sait sur un malentendu
peut-être que ça peut passer même si les
chances semblent minces c'est quand même
intéressant parce que c'est pas
seulement oui il ya une prime au sortant
lié au contexte sanitaire à la
difficulté d'avoir du débat ans et
parlait politique durant toute cette
période
mais alors il y aussi les sortants front
national front national qui ont été
battus et moi ils ont tous été battus
dans l'eau à sa mafia sont également on
a retrouvé jean lain la capelle je sais
pas si vous avez entendu ce que disaient
nos interlocuteurs en plateau on a eu un
peu de mal à vous retrouver mais marine
le pen si elle ne gagne pas en 2022 ce
que politiquement c'est terminé pour
elle d'après vous la question ne se pose
pas aujourd'hui
la question se posera après l'élection
présidentielle voulu te bien qu'en
parler aujourd'hui
mais c'est ne pas être sensible sur les
onze jeux sur l'époque bas sont des
français donc je ne sais pas si tu es
leur intervention a été coupée mais je
je je je tenais à dire que je crois que
nous avons été conscient très rapidement
nous allons dénoncer très tôt depuis 40
ans d'ailleurs que les problématiques
des français étaient liés emprunt de la
sécurité de l'immigration l'islam
radical je le disais la souveraineté
industrielle de l'écologie ou deux de la
la la fiscalité
je crois que nous serons prêts pour
représenter un programme aux français et
les français ont rendez vous des
élections régionales départementales
bien sûr qui n'a pas recueilli les
suffrages nous attendions donc nous
avons été déçus et je veux pas je vais
pas bien à mon démo d'ettore de cette
déception mais elle a concerné tous les
partis politiques les français ont été
désintéresser de cette double eric sur
locales et déception de ne pas dire des
pressions et ça n'a pas été et j'ai cru
comprendre que votre l'un d'eux l'un de
vos invités disait que les gens à voter
à droite à gauche trois ils ont voté
pour le président sortant
il ya eu 13 présidents 13 président de
l'hôtellerie
ils ont parti socialiste s'est pas voter
républicain
ils ont voté pour le président de région
auxquels ils ont cru maintenant
attention hein
restons humbles la la la le gr électorat
qui est si faible que non plus c'est pas
extrêmement révélateur et on va
s'arrêter là pour ce chapitre merci jean
la capelle d'avoir participé au match
des idées quelques minutes et pardon
pour la liaison un peu un peu compliqué
on a reparlé à présent d'edouard
philippe héros d'une série documentaire
et doit à mon pote de droite
réalisé par laurence si bien avec la
participation de france télévisions et
de public sénat
hier soir était diffusé le troisième
volet intitulé aux manettes comprenez
aux manettes de matignon bien sûr il
revient sur pas mal de sujets notamment
sur les difficultés de l'exercice du
pouvoir pendant la crise sanitaire
regardez c'est vrai qu'en ce moment j'ai
un peu l'impression d'être tu sais je
conduis un car j'ai des mondes derrière
il ya un soin sur deux qui fonctionne
pas il ya du brouillard et du verglas et
on est dans une route de montagne et ta
ta ta ta cinq types dans le car qui
disent mais non il fallait tourner à
droite
il fallait tourner à gauche et puis tu
as les autres qui disputaient les terres
qui a pas se planter quoi bon ça
ressemble un tube face à ben jawad en ce
moment vous ne pas s'énerver vaut mieux
rester calmes et et puis essayer de
regarder la route et de penser qu'à ça
quoi mais ce qui est drôle c'est que tu
croises des gens et ça c'est très
réconfortant
ils te disent mais on voit bien vous
êtes en train d'essayer de
conduire le ce de carla qui
convoie bien donc continuer fait le bien
alors dans quelle catégorie vous êtes
roxane lundi vous êtes corinne tous un
peu dans la catégorie des cinq tirs qui
disent non faire et son aide à l'étang
des gauches pour connaître un peu
non non non je crois pas je crois que
justement on a vu tout au long de la
crise sanitaire enfin pour le coup on a
été très attentifs les uns les autres
décisions qui étaient prises il faut
qu'il ya une opposition qui a été très
constructive
alors oui bien sûr on a tous aussi
découvert appris à vivre avec
avec ce virus découvert en même temps
que le gouvernement nous annonçait un
certain nombre de choses alors avec
beaucoup de colère parfois je pense pas
au scandale démasqués aux élections qui
se sont tenues sans masque avec des
contaminations terrible et là c'est vrai
que c'est dur d'en rire et de se dire on
voit là
on aurait pu faire autrement on aurait
dû faire autrement c'est sûr maintenant
c'est vrai que de voir cette sortie
maintenant après la crise quand on voit
tous les aléas qu'on a eu et le fait
bien sûr n'en est pas complètement sorti
hélas que ce que le débat qui va tout à
l'heure et est très intéressant ça
permet aussi de remettre en perspective
et de se dire que oui on a été dans une
période politique un peu particulière
avec un débat politique extrêmement
particulier et je crois que personne
n'avait complètement les clés mais par
contre on tire le bilan aujourd'hui de
ce qui a été fait par edouard philippe
qui est pas exactement la même chose que
monsieur castex et ça c'est intéressant
aussi pour pour la suite quand un lesur
vous faisiez partie de ceux qui il ya
deux choses on sait très bien en toute
honnêteté que n'importe quel
gouvernement qui aurait dû gérer la
crise en mars 2020 aurait pris cher si
vous me permettez l'expression parce que
voilà on ya eu c'est arrivé avec 1 on
peut toujours effectivement dire manque
d'anticipation et autres et est venu
dans un second temps effectivement le
temps de la colère vis-à-vis des
incohérences parce que derrière il y
avait effectivement quand je vois
aujourd'hui à quel point les leçons
foisonnent il y avait des morts il y
avait des restrictions des conséquences
économiques sociales et voilà c'est vrai
que les masques c'était quand même assez
extraordinaire on est passé de
l'inutilité totale à l'impérieuse
nécessité ordres et contre ordres des
élections mais avec à la clé sur la avec
amende à la clef bon moi j'étais tête de
liste aux municipales on a vécu un
scandale démocratique
absolute à dire vraiment une une
élection complètement liquidé dont il
fallait très vite se débarrasser entre
avec 3,3 ma différence on va vraiment
delà de la grosse du gros tripatouillage
qu'on aurait pu éviter où on était
capable de faire revoter de manière
correcte
donc oui il a eu un peu la colère
maintenant bon d'ailleurs la colère
continue parce qu'on en est
saison saison 2 épisode épisode 3 ou 4
peut-être et au final bon ben oui
edouard philippe revient sur le sueur
sur cette partie je crois qu'il n'était
pas mécontent de s'en aller il ya un an
de matignon et puis il a été
paradoxalement suivi par un monsieur qui
était monsieur déconfinement et qui en
fait a majoritairement dans son temps
était monsieur confinement en fait et il
nous reste deux minutes peut-être la fin
ce documentaire que sur la suite pour
edouard philippe edouard philippe dit au
documentariste qui est donc son ami vous
l'aurez compris je n'ai pas honte de ce
que je fais de la façon dont je les fais
j'en suis moi même c'est heureux et
voilà je passe à autre chose laurent si
bien lui répond je ne te demanderai pas
quoi et d'un philippe autre chose
grand sourire bon général il ira pas
alors est-ce qu'il ira peut-être parce
qu'après tout c'est l'apprentissage des
manuels macron le fait de pouvoir dire à
tous les responsables politiques que
vous ayez un parti un collectif ou pas
c'est l'individualisme qui prime
et puis vous y allez vous racontez votre
propre histoire finalement edouard
philippe peut faire une emmanuel macron
c'est vrai après est-ce que ça ça me
parle et on tape les trahisons
est ce que certains pourraient appeler
trahison mais finalement il ya une forme
de cohérence il était le premier
ministre devrait mieux le maquereau qui
était lui même l'un des ministres de
françois hollande
il ya une forme de proximité mais ce qui
est intéressant dans ce qui disait tout
à l'heure c'est qu'ils parlaient de la
gestion de cette crise puisse-t-il aussi
avoir tiré des enseignements de cette
crise fallait l'explosion des inégalités
notamment chez les jeunes qui n'arrivent
plus à se nourrir enfin
le fait que yilin maintient le cap le
fait qu'on continue à sacrifier les
services publics malgré cette crise et
notamment les hôpitaux qui est pas de
moyens supplémentaires qui a été mise en
place via un puits style aussi en tirer
des conséquences
et demain aussi doit être candidat et
bien qu'ils aillent le faire sur
l'échiquier politique ça vous fera un
candidat exclu non edouard philippe
très honnêtement là je dis pas du tout
uniquement en tant qu en tant que
représentant des verts sur ce plateau
edouard philippe à une expérience d'élu
local d'une grande ville
il a une certaine prestance en tant
qu'homme d'état on peut pas forcément
dire mais il faut avoir une analyse
objective maintenant quand il ya de la
droite évidemment que non
il ya des raisons politiques évidentes
candidat contre emmanuel macron je ne
crois absolument pas non plus je pense
qu'il sera avant tout l'outil de ce
rééquilibrage du centre de gravité macro
n'ya vers la droite auquel je faisais
référence sur tout sauf si emmanuel
macron se retrouver plutôt un pédophile
pourrait être un candidat de
remplacement aux dernières minutes si
emmanuel macron indiquant cliché je sais
pas des consolantes des conséquences
terribles par exemple suite à une
réforme des retraites qui nous semble
imminente qui rendrait la merci à tous
les deux d'avoir participé à ce match 27
émissions se retrouvent demain à 18
heures et à 22h30 dans un instant
auditions publiques l'invité ce soir
barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique demain 7h30
bonjour chez vous aurez un nanti niro
sera notamment patrick mignola président
du groupe modem à l'assemblée excellente
soirée sur public sénat